We always
love doing the Unexpected with Scott Lang,
Ant-Man is arguably the character
that is the most underestimated.
Man became the key to saving the universe
in Avengers Endgame.
So carrying that tradition, we thought,
Well, let's use
this film to kick off Phase five.
It's been almost a decade now
and I've been playing this part.
I've loved it and I feel protective
of Scott Lang and Ant-Man.
It's really nice coming back.
I still can't believe that
I'm sitting there and it's like,
Wow, there's Michelle Pfeiffer
and there's Michael Douglas.
I just saved eight books. God,
I admire you.
It's really nice
not to get used to working with legends.
You're sending a signal down
to the quantum realm
where
there's a secret universe beneath ours.
Janet has been very quiet about her
time in the quantum realm.
Maybe would have made different choices.
There's someone I never told you about.
This place isn't what you think.
Kang the Conqueror is terrifying.
And if there ever was a maniac loose
in the quantum realm, it's him
playing Kang the Conqueror.
It's such a gift. Your reality.
Everything you're holding on to.
I know how it ends.
This is the beginning.
And he cannot be contained.
Something like this, which is so
transportive and visually striking.
People should really see it in movie
theaters.
You want it to be as big
and as visceral and consuming as possible.
Audiences are going to watch this and go,
I can't believe this is happening.
It's going to be bonkers.
It's like we're camping.
We never been camping,
but we've always talked about it.
Welcome back, everyone.
It's Charlie
Marvel dropped the new Ant-Man
and the Wasp Quantumania trailer video
with all the characters talking about
what's happening during the movie.
Bunch of big Easter eggs.
Obviously this is meant to set up
a bunch of stuff.
It's the beginning of Marvel Phase
five in Avengers five, Qing Dynasty.
If you're brand new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos.
We're also doing a giveaway for Ant-Man
and the Wasp Quantumania.
Tickets.
Because it's coming out so soon, I'll name
a new giveaway winner
at the end of this too.
What are the biggest things during this?
Is Kevin V explaining why they took
such a left turn with the Ant-Man
franchise for this film
in the way that Paul Rudd talked about it.
He actually used a lot of Thor
Ragnarok references in the way that Thor
Ragnarok was like a dramatic left
turn for the Thor franchise.
After Thor, The Dark World was like
such a serious, dark movie.
He and Kevin Zeigler basically
saying they wanted to essentially
do the exact same thing with Ant-Man,
but in the opposite direction.
Like normally you think of Ant-Man, movies
typically is comedies
first with some action in them.
But because this was the third film
in the franchise, they wanted to take
a dramatic turn with it and make it way
more hardcore than people were expecting,
which is why it seems that they're rolling
so hard on Ant-Man in this.
Like,
even though I think that he'll wind up
surviving the end of the movie,
they really, really want you to think
that Kang is going to kill him
during the film, or he's
going to sacrifice himself to stop Kang
But I don't think he's going to kill him.
And I don't think that Ant-Man
is going to be successful in stopping Kang
from escaping the quantum realm.
Like, literally the word dynasty is across
all of these last couple of trailers.
They really want you to think
that this is going to be
the version of Kang the Conqueror,
the variant of Kang the Conqueror.
That will be the one.
The Avengers phase during Avengers
five, Kang Dynasty.
There's also a lot of unreleased footage
where they have even more references
to Avengers
five Qing Dynasty in a lot of the actors,
not just Paul Rudd, not just Kevin
Feige, have said that they really wanted
to kick things into high gear
during Marvel Phase five,
even though this is melees
during Marvel phase.
For a lot of them trying out new things,
they really wanted Marvel Phase
five to be them actually pushing
the overarching plot forward.
Like here's
where things really get started.
And because things are rolling
so hard in Ant-Man,
they were taking such a dramatic turn
with things,
surprising people in such a big way.
That's why they chose to make it
the first Marvel Phase five movie.
Also, because the whole idea that Kang
the Conqueror
was going to be the main villain
just line things up
so they could set up Avengers
five, Qing Dynasty and Marvel Phase six.
It would have been
a dramatically different movie
if Kang had not been in this,
and they just made Modok
the ruler down here in the quantum realm.
What are the interesting Easter eggs too?
Like we talk about all the Kang variants
that we're going to see during Marvel
Phase five.
We'll see a bunch of them
during Loki Season two,
like a bunch of the other versions
of Kang, but done as different variants
is the way they're explaining Kang getting
the conquer name during this movie.
Now he remains in the Loki finale.
Use the term conquer.
So like they already tease
Kang the Conqueror, some of us
new worlds
meant only one thing
new lands to be conquered.
But in all Marvel movies,
they try to explain how villains or heroes
get the actual name. Like somebody
at some point gives them the name
or they come up with it themselves.
All the different variants,
real names are Nathaniel Richards,
like they were born Nathaniel Richards,
and then became different variants
of the character
calling themselves different things.
Why did this one start calling himself
Kang and why did they start calling him
Kang the Conqueror?
And it turns out the way
they're explaining his name during
this movie is that when he was stranded
in the quantum realm,
like he was a traveler of the multiverse
and got stranded
and then was trying to get Janet
Van Dyne help in escaping
so that he could continue
winning the Kang Multiverse War
when she stranded him
in the quantum realm.
The second time
by disabling his time ship,
he went on to conquer the quantum realm.
He is the conqueror of the quantum realm,
and that's why they call him Kang
the Conqueror.
He didn't get the conqueror name
until he crashed in the quantum realm.
But one of my early theories, too,
because they're setting him up to be such
a big overarching villain in Marvel Phase
five and Marvel Phase six is that
this will be the variant of Kang who
actually started the Kang Multiverse War
because when he remains
was talking about his back story
and how the Kang Multiverse War
basically led to this all out war,
destroying all timelines everywhere
until he was able to stop it with a life
he never actually said which Kang was
the one that actually started the war.
Like at some point, one of them
had to conquer one of the other timelines.
And then it started all out war.
And I think what they're trying to explain
in this movie
is that the person that started it all
was this variant of Kang.
And I love the way Michelle Pfeiffer jokes
about what she was up to
while she was stuck in the quantum
realm for 20, 30 plus years.
Like, it would have been helpful
if she had told everyone else
about what had happened
with Kang the Conqueror,
because it seems like a lot of them
are finding out for the first time
when they get sucked into the quantum
realm by Kang himself in the whole thing
with this dark past of hers
that they're teasing is just her
inadvertently helping him continue
his quest to win the Kang Multiverse War
and ultimately, theoretically destroy
all of reality.
It seems like what happened
between the two of them in the past,
like this untold story that you saw,
we find out through the course of the film
is that she landed there.
They're both scientists.
They tried to find a way to escape.
Like Kang gave her the same deal
that he offers to me.
And I can help you get more time
with your family, get time back.
But at the time, Kang found her and
he was stranded trying to find a way out.
He lied to her
about what he was truly trying to do,
what his true intentions were in Y.
She was busy trying to help him find a way
getting out of the quantum realm.
She learned his secret
and then disabled his time ship.
A lot of people
also asking about this device too.
Like they posted a new picture.
This almost seems like a flashback of Kang
because he's not wearing his suit
like he's
just wearing a normal tunic here.
It still looks like the trademark green
and purple, though.
This is the engine for his time ship
that allows him to cross
between realities, between timelines.
They haven't fully explained
what exactly powers it, what it was
that Janet Van Dyne stole,
like the power source in where she hid it.
A lot of people
asking about the Forever Crystal
because that was a big part
of the Avengers Forever storyline.
It was like a big MacGuffin in
They are basing
some of what happens in Marvel Phase
five Marvel, Phase six in the Qing Dynasty
on the Avengers Forever storyline.
I might do a separate video about that
at some point
because it is a really interesting story,
but they did explain the place
where Kang brings
Ant-Man to look for the device that Jenny
Van Dyne had is a quantum nexus,
so to speak.
Like this place is the quantum nexus,
and part of the idea
with some of these other characters
that you've seen,
like you see a couple of familiar actors
here is that there is a resistance
to Kang Building in the Quantum realm,
like he conquered
the quantum realm, meaning
that he killed a whole bunch of people.
And all these people are meant to be like
the grassroots inhabitants
of the quantum realm
who lived here before he came along.
They're trying to get rid of him,
and they wind up working with Ant-Man
and the others to try and stop Kang.
But the whole idea is
that he's trying to escape
and take the army that he built with him.
The funny thing, too,
and I think they explain
this is some of the earlier trailers,
is that the army that you see
like his dynasty as they tease it,
he actually didn't create that
until Janet Van Dyne stranded him
and he was stuck there.
Time moves a little bit differently
in the quantum realm,
so it might have actually been longer.
But part of the idea
is that when Janet Van Dyne
was still trying to help him
before she learned his secret
and she was able to escape, he didn't
have this giant army
like it was just him in his time ship.
Really cool here. And Jonathan Majors
talk about the character, too.
I love the hype around the character.
You should have seen them the last couple
of conventions that they took him to.
He's going to be like
the new version of the Thanos was right.
Meme Kang was right.
One of the biggest things
they haven't revealed yet
is why he started the Kang Multiverse War.
Like,
why even begin it in the first place?
Because the way that he who remains talked
about their collective backstory,
like all the Kang variants, is
that they were mostly scientists
trying to help each other, enhance each
other's universes, each other's timelines.
The group of Kang's he talked about coming
together was a teaser
for the counsel of Kang's in the way
that he talked about, at least at first,
made it sound like
it was actually a good thing.
Like for a time
there was peace in the multiverse
and we all worked
for the betterment of our realities.
But as he goes on, he says, eventually
other Kang's came along
the only other realities
to conquer, quote unquote.
And that's when he's talking about this
Kang the Conqueror variant.
There've been a lot of rumors
about another variant of Kang
being a version of the Beyond
and being even more powerful
like the Beyond.
Her was in the comics
then Kang the Conqueror and being the true
villain of Avengers Secret Wars.
That's part of the early theory
that the New Avengers
will not be strong enough
to stop Kang the Conqueror.
Like nobody can stop Kang
except for another Kang.
And when we get to the end of Avengers
five Qing Dynasty, The Avengers will lose,
but another Kang variant will come along.
Kill this Kang the Conqueror
and then collapse the multiverse
into the one reality
like the battle world reality for a comic
book version of Secret Wars,
where Doctor Strange looks amongst
the surviving people from other realities
to assemble a multiverse avengers.
And they use
that as sort of like a big send off
for all the Fox Marvel
actors, All the Fox Fantastic Four people,
the people who they're going to recast
in new MCU movies.
Tobey Maguire, Andrew Garfield.
Spider-Man are supposed to come back
for that too.
Like Secret Wars will be everyone
else's movie, all these legacy actors.
And then when we go forward and Marvel
Phase seven,
then they'll start recasting
some of the X-Men characters.
I think that's why they're waiting,
particularly
to recast a new version of Wolverine.
There's also some rumors that there's
some contractual reasons why Kevin Feige
has to wait till like 20, 25, 2026
to recast some of those roles.
So we just made sense practically for him
to bring a lot
of those actors
back for one big sendoff movie.
And that's going to be Secret Wars.
I know there's still a bunch of questions
about what's happening with Kang
and the other variants
during Loki Season two,
because those episodes
will also be coming later this year.
But the next big Marvel series
is going to be Secret Invasion.
We'll probably see a teaser or a trailer
for that at the Super Bowl in a couple
other big Marvel trailers
in addition to other people's trailers.
So of course they'll do videos
for all that stuff.
Just leave
all your requests in the comments below.
Congratulations C.J Handley.
You're the giveaway winner
from my last big Marvel video.
Please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details.
Everyone click here for my full Last of US
episode videos and click here
for my new Flash trailer and a first
look at that evil version of The Flash.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.